crisis what crisis after the drama and
Chaos of the weekend this is Russia's
political and Military leadership trying
to show that everything is fine Vladimir
Putin speaking to an industrial forum
and the first footage of the defense
minister released since Wagner boss
yevgeni pregosian called for his sacking
and launched a short-lived Mutiny
briefly advancing on Moscow
though we don't know when it was filmed
the message is clear it's the Kremlin
saying no mercenary leader can force
Vladimir Putin to do anything
at a government meeting prime minister
mashustan urged Russians to unify
we need to act together as one team and
maintain the unity of all our forces
rallying around the president we need to
take calculated unified decisions to
effectively achieve goals set by the
leader of the state but for observers in
the west the events are signs that
Russia's war in Ukraine has exposed deep
Fishers in the Russian president's hold
on power the monster that Putin created
with the bangner the monster is biting
him now
the monster is acting against his
creator the political system is in
showing the facilities
and the military power is cracking so
this is an important consequence of the
world and Japan
China is concerned by the possibility of
a chaotic State collapse in its
strategic partner Russia but the foreign
Ministry is saying little Beyond General
words of support
the incident of Wagner group you
mentioned is Russia's internal Affair as
Russia's friendly neighbor and
comprehensive strategic partner of
coordination for the new era China
supports Russia maintaining National
stability in achieving development and
prosperity
Evgeni pregosian is supposedly headed
for Belarus in the deal brokered by
Bella Russian President Alexander
lukashenko pregosian was initially
understood to have had Mutiny charges
against him in Russia dropped but some
Russian media are reporting the Wagner
boss remains under investigation Rory
challenge Al Jazeera
foreign Ministers of the European Union